HE RECENTLY SAT DOWN WITH
MIKE ROWE TO DISCUSS THE
PROBLEM.
HERE IS THE CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: MIKE ROWE, THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
>> TUCKER, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME.
>> Tucker: SO YOU HAVE SPENT
A LOT OF YOUR ADULT LIFE
WATCHING MEN WORK.
WHAT THEY DO, HOW LONG THEY
DO IT, WHY THEY DO IT.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
MEN CAN'T WORK, WHEN THEY
ARE OUT OF WORK, WHEN THEY
ARE IDLE AND CAN'T PROVIDE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO MEN?
>> WELL, YOUR SOUL SLIPS OUT
OF YOU.
IT'S THE FROG IN THE BOILING
WATER.
NOTHING GOOD HAPPENS BUT THE
DIRECT RESULT UNFOLD IN A
KIND OF DISASTER SCENARIO.
YOU BECOME DISENGAGED.
YOU BECOME EMASCULATED.
YOU START TO ASK YOURSELF A
WHOLE LOT OF QUESTIONS.
YOU CAN'T POSSIBLY ANSWER.
AND THEN, IF IT GETS BAD.
IT TURNS IN ON ITSELF AND
YOU BECOME RESENTFUL AND YOU
LOOK FOR SOMEONE TO BLAME.
AND ULTIMATELY, YOU SQUARE
OFF.
SOMETIMES AGAINST YOUR OWN
FAMILY.
SOMETIMES AGAINST YOUR
CO-WORKERS.
SOMETIMES AGAINST YOURSELF.
LONG WAY OF SAYING NOTHING
GOOD.
>> Tucker: IT'S A DISASTER
AS YOU JUST POINTED OUT NOT
JUST FOR THE UNEMPLOYED MAN
BUT FOR EVERYONE AROUND HIM
AND FOR THE SOCIETY ITSELF.
GIVEN THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S CLEARLY TRUE, HAVE
YOU GOT 7 MILLION MEN OF
WORKING AGE OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE NOW AND NOBODY
TALKS WITH
TALK AWITH
TALK ABOTH
TALK ABOUT IT.
IT SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING
APPROACHING A SOCIAL CRISIS.
WHY ISN'T THAT IN THE NEWS
MORE?
>> I THINK BECAUSE WE CAN'T
DECIDE WHO TO BLAME, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT'S NOT NEWS UNLESS
THERE IS A BAD GUY.
SO WE NEED A VILLAIN.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE SOMEBODY
IN A BLACK HAT.
AND WE LOOK AROUND.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF
POTENTIAL VILLAINS.
BUT THE HARD TRUTH, I'M
AFRAID, IN MY VIEW AND,
AGAIN, I'M NOT AN EXPERT IN
ANY OF IT.
BUT I THINK THAT A LOT OF
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS
SELF-INFLICTED.
I THINK MEN BECOMING
SOMEWHAT DISCONNECTED FROM
WHATEVER VERSION OF MANHOOD
THEY ESPOUSE, I THINK THAT
HAPPENS BECAUSE OF
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
DAD, WITH THEIR GRAND
FATHER, YOU KNOW.
GRAND FATHERS AREN'T AROUND
ANYMORE.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE ROLE
OF FATHERS.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S BEEN
FRACTURED BUT IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY, REALLY, WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE SAFETY
NET A KID HAD GROWING UP.
THERE WAS A DAD THERE AND
THERE WAS A GRAND FATHER
THERE.
AND THERE WAS INERTIA AND A
LOT OF THINGS THAT THE KID
COULD LOOK TO NOT JUST FOR
IDEAS AND VIRTUES BUT FOR
PROOF, YOU KNOW.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> SO THAT'S GONE.
THAT'S NOT JUST A PROBLEM
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL.
IT'S A PROBLEM, I THINK, IF
YOU THINK A CULTURE HAS AN
IDENTITY, IF YOU THINK A
SOCIETY AS A SOUL, THESE ARE
THE ENEMIES OF THOSE THINGS.
>> Tucker: THERE IS KNOW
REQUEST
QUQUEST
QUESEST
QUESTIT
QUESTION ABOUT IT DO YOU
THINK WE VALUE WORK AS
INHERENT VIRTUE AS A
SOCIETY?
>> NO.
NO, I DON'T.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED WORK AS THE
PROXIMATE CAUSE OF OUR
DISSATISFACTION.
AND I THINK YOU DON'T HAVE
TO LOOK FAR TO FIND ENDLESS
EXAMPLES.
LOOK, THE BEST SELLING BOOKS
RIGHT NOW IN THE SELF-HELP
SECTION AND IN GENERAL
CLAIMED TO HAVE THE SOLUTION
FOR HOW YOU CAN WORK LESS.
MOST OF THE COMMERCIALS ON
TV ASK A TACET QUESTION, HOW
COULD YOU BE HAPPIER?
AND THE ANSWER, OF COURSE IS
RETIRE A LITTLE SOONER OR
WORK 35 INSTEAD OF 40 HOURS.
ARE TYPICALLY VALUED TEND TO
EMBRACE NOTIONS OF
SHORTCUTS, YOU KNOW.
IN A THOUSAND DIFFERENT